it's lovely to see you here today and
cone amy has been enjoying it I have had
the best time it's so much fun just
actually getting to meet all the fans
and interact with them and it's just the
best fun I really enjoyed it yeah I
could've had a princess in the show
didn't you what was that like it was so
cool it was ever it was honestly every
little girls dream especially mine
because I've always wanted to act so
acting a princess was like a veil the
ultimate goal I mean the dresses and the
makeup and the hair I just I felt like
the luckiest girl in the world looking
back now at your time on the show what
are the highlights of you what the
memories that gonna stay with you to
think honestly just I like I can't pick
a one moment and think yeah that was the
best part cuz it's not there wasn't it
was just every time I was on set I was
so happy and every time everyone I met
made me feel like I was just one of the
gang and even you know the higher up
really well-known actors he would maybe
expect to not be so nice to the younger
kids like me everybody was just so
wonderful and sweet and all of my scenes
were so much fun and if I had to pick
like one thing I would say Croatia who
doesn't want two weeks in Croatia you
had a lot of different scenes like very
didn't with a lot of different members
of cast as well you quite lucky you got
to meet a lot of different people but if
you kind of could pick maybe one
highlight or two of out of those various
scenes what would it be anything and I
think that probably my favorite seemed
to film well of two would have been in
the second season my last episode when I
was being shipped off because that was
actually my last day filming too so the
tears were real and everyone was there
because it was big scene Selena and
Peter and Sophie and Jack we're all
there and it was just one of the
loveliest days and it was a really
lovely warm day and I was actually in
the boat and I had I was surrounded by
people in the boat who were extra
but they were also trained and like
health and safety so I didn't fall in
even though it was by that date but it
was really good fun and there was one
guy in the boat he kept singing to me
because he was like don't cry and I was
like I'm acting I'm supposed to cry and
he was so he would sing to me between
takes and this is no play
the whole day was just brilliant
together were these singing so you do
remember it wasn't an actual song he was
just going don't cry baby don't cry and
he did not have a good singing voice and
we neither do I fit and this was like a
fit middle-aged creation man trying to
speak broken English and it wasn't good
well it was very sweet yeah I mean it
was very sad but to hear when we found
out that you weren't gonna be you coming
back as miss Ella I mean although I was
cheered up by your vine I'm a sir thank
you I mean what did you feel when you
found out that you weren't gonna be
coming back I mean obviously it was
heartbreaking nobody wants to get that
news especially since acting as
something I want to do with my life but
when you go into this industry it's
something you've just got to expect
rejection and heartbreak and not getting
the part and getting recast and
everything it's part of the job and I
think that in a way it's actually made
me a lot stronger and a lot more
determined to go into this industry and
succeed because neither I know even
though I've obviously had auditions that
I haven't got in the past there was
never that that thing so know that I've
survived that and come back stronger I
feel like I can take on anything so it's
yeah I think that I'm gonna look back on
it certainly and think yeah that was the
right thing for to happen to me when did
you come up with the idea for your
princess for higher vayan
like I don't really know my mum was like
you should make a vine about this and I
was like mom it just happened
are you kidding me why insensitive and
she was like all right and then a few
months later when it was officially
released I was like
and then I don't know it just kind of
came out of nowhere cuz I had made a
couple of other vines using that
crawling so I was like mommy will you
film something on the street with me
sure I don't really know where it came
from but it certainly got a good
reaction yeah I like the way needed when
you do it when Joffrey popped his clogs
as well yeah that was what that one was
a bit embarrassing after I got rejas and
I was like oh no that's definitely not
gonna happen nice but yes I liked that
one at the time looking behind the
scenes for you what was it like for you
filming as Miss Ella
what were those days like takes the
beauty behind and give it to the kind of
insight the people who don't know it was
the most surreal experience of my life
because I was only eleven oh I was 10
when we shot the pilot so to suddenly be
thrown into this world of just fantasy
and dresses and wonderful people and
doing the thing that I loved more than
anything else in the world it was
incredible and I feel like it was a
proper family on set and that's the most
cheesy thing I've ever said but
everybody really got along and there was
no tension or nobody thought they were
too good for anyone else and we would
all say over lunch together huddled
around a heater or something so it's
always freezing that's something they
don't tell you it's freezing even when
you're supposedly in Dorne freezing yeah
but and yeah I think it was just the
most incredible experience and for this
to be one of I've done a few things
before this but for this to be one of my
first big things it was a really
wonderful way to start it off yeah
finally what was it like filming with
for example Lena and and also Peter as
well it was like an acting masterclass
like just sitting beside him on sat and
watching them act it was like watching a
painter it was so beautiful I just think
they're so talented and they deserve so
much recognition and I'll go through
they get some that I feel
lene especially needs awards she needs a
wall in her house covered with Emmys and
Oscars and everything she's incredible
I mean if she just showed how the
subtlety of what she died was like a
twitch of an eyebrow or you know
slightly lifting her lip or something it
can convey so much just so little and I
think that's why she's such a wonderful
actress and Jack firmly was Jack was the
weirdest thing because he is the
loveliest sweetest funniest most
down-to-earth guy I've ever met and then
you walk on set and they say action and
it's like Psychopaths and he is so good
at what he does to be able to just flip
between Psychopaths and Jack it's
ridiculous so yeah he's absolutely
brilliant and you know people who
usually don't believe me when I say that
he's nice because her like no he can't
yes thank you so much Amy
you